هو اول حكم اعدام بحق متظاهر في ايران منذ
الاحتجاجات التي اندلعت في البلاد قبل
شهرين الحكم القضائي صدر خلال محاكمه
متهمين بالضلوع في اعمال شغب في محافظه
طهران يوم الاحد افادت وسائل اعلام
ايرانيه عن توجيه القضاء الاتهام الى نحو
800 شخص لضلوعهم في اعمال شغب وقعت مؤخرا
في ثلاث محافظات بحسب مصادر غربيه اعتقل
اكثر من 15,000 شخص ضمن الاعتقالات
الجماعيه التي شهدتها البلاد منذ ثمانيه
اسابيع
تتراوحدها بين التحريض على القتل والدعايه
ضد النظام والاخلال بالنظام العام
الاحتجاجات اندلعت في اعقابي وفاه الشاب
مهزميني بعد ثلاثه ايام من توقيفها من قبل
الشرطه الاخلاق لعدم التزامها القواعد
الصارمه لللباس في الجمهوريه الاسلاميه
دعامات عده دول غربيه لاحتجاجات فيما تتهم
طهران هذه الدول بمحاوله اشعال فتنه داخل
ايران يوم الاثنين من المتوقع ان يعلن
وزراء خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي عقوبات
جديده ضد ايران